what is up ladies you can see the air
between the shack and the head positive
growth what's up everybody my name is
Michael Hughes I'm a trainer at churches
back to June 2012 we don't go to the
Gloves champion yeah what's up everybody
Kenny Ocean I'm also training an
accessory boxing gym I'm a New York
bison 2008 winner 2017 today we're gonna
be fatiguing Hollywood boxing films no
more explosive real from the fake that's
what we hear the dope we got our first
film I leave one my favorite boxing
movies very dramatic fighting I'll be on
the ropes we've taken a lot of flows but
it looked like he's really taking a
blows doing pretty good I'll leave mimic
movements popping that jab move in you'd
let him fly a little bit
that's not bad it's a pretty good combo
now you can't tell you didn't like this
movie look at his face tad bit that was
good movement by will I like the little
faint movements he did overall really
say the movements is like it's just like
that was kind of old I was always mad at
waste looks but like the action shot
here welcome if you could tell he
definitely studied his alley food he
mimicked the I leave jab pretty well put
a little bit too dramatic where a
person's getting their offense off and
the other person is just like too much
of like it's like a heavy bag overall
that wasn't too bad Will Smith did his
homework so next up we got one of the a
boxing classic Raging Bull I sort of got
he's indicating immodest movements
pretty well with the lean in all right
the one thing with this off the RIP it's
just too much of a dramatic fight scene
where he's letting off three four or
five shots he's just getting ripped it's
just too easy look at that reason if
that was the real Ray Robinson he would
have clipped him I don't know and you
can kind of see some of the punches when
they're throwing and you can see the
head turning it's nice not like a queen
feet kick I'll get that I'll get a
little bit like that you know
knock somebody down get that little
puppy attest Robinson was getting hit
way too easily LaMotta was throwing like
a four five six like left right combo a
Robinson and Robinson's head was just
Bob we're heading with no deviance
that's not really like I feel like Ray
Robinson could've been portrayed better
alone yeah definitely Robert De Niro
though mimic Jake LaMotta really well
Raging Bull style coming forward with
the pressure
next up Million Dollar Baby another
classic but Hilary Swank is moving on a
feat she's carrying pretty well oh she
would get tagged ahead with pop which is
kind of realistic if you're backing up
and you get his ended a punch to hey kid
snap back the footboard isn't too bad
though he started off pretty okay and
she caught it with these two bombing
hooks she really took Donghae yeah she's
got white cover in full guard was
eye-opening yes this is the scene I'm
gonna knock over all this film is great
though all right now always but this
you're like he's going up a street fight
oh that was kind of fake saw you okay
okay
unless he's psychic that was me yeah he
anticipated that a little bit too well
you can tell that they prepared by doing
some like legit pad work for this but
then it looks like they're doing pad
work in the fight scene that gotta look
real oh I don't even believe that
because though he's stand-in super far
away and he just rips him with a
overhand right with no setup you could
tell that they try to make it more
realistic but at the same time to me and
look like boxing pad work pad work is
when you have your trainer folding pads
pulling all combinations you could see
like a clear combo where it's like slip
slip roll hook hook cross
roll six three you do one more thing
with Crete where he gets a
he gets dropped and the reference
counting one two and he gets up like
seven eight nine and he just like
Springs he's like unconscious in real
life you're not gonna go from to pop it
up they're never in life would you ever
see that happen this is rocky I love
this Mike say he hate it I don't know
why for the record I don't hate it
the boxing okay okay I got I got I got
steady
that's cold terms for problems Oh boxing
a power create I lose do you see the
bobblehead is that next snap is
Christmas but look a problem you can see
the air between the shot bro well you
can't tell me that boxing Rock'em oh
hell do you see right here now is that
was the best exchange that look like
follow-through back that was the best
bro
now comes no way rocky been on that ass
apollomon trying to keep away with that
jab bang bang snap that jab he's looking
good why you doing it I like that little
clinch fighting for us for two seconds
that's realistic yeah he gave me some
other thoughts can't do dental ring
that's a dirty trick that's yo Ken so
throw a right hand over here it's like
that every punch in rock like that did
you been to the fight Stallone you
wouldn't like the Hall of Fame baby I
need to see some more technical boxing
for the new film right salute though the
thing is for like the general public
we're boxes so we can notice the little
technical things for the general public
a person who has never been in a fight
in their life street fight or in the
ring otherwise they don't know what
they're seeing they see a punch land
ahead pop oh my god it's the best thing
ever but to a person who's a boxer and
you know that technicalities it ain't
real
[Music]